اسرائيل
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
القياده الجويه الامريكيه حول حول هل
تسمعني حول الطائرات الروسيه تحلق فوق
رؤوسنا ما الذي يحدث يا ساده بينما هنا
مصر تتجاهل الولايات المتحده والسبب روسيا
واشنطن تفرض العقوبات على موسكو لتصرخ
اوروبا هي تفرض ولا تنفذ فما الذي يجري
ونحو الف صاروخ فلسطيني تتجه نحو الكيان
وتل ابيب تفتح الملاجئ وتعلن حاله الطوارئ
القصوى حركه حماس تدخل خط المواجهه وتشعل
الحرب ضد الاحتلال
تذكر اليابان بدرسه روشيما بينما امريكا
تتجه لمعاقبه الدول العربيه بسبب سوريا
وصفقه عسكريه ملياريه بين برلين و واشنطن
واشنطن تكسر عقوبات اوروبا
الامريكانو يفرضون العقوبات كما يتنفسون
يعاقبون كل من اقترب من روسيا اضغطون
يحذرون ويهددون لا للاقتراب من موسكو لكن
مجله يزويك الامريكية تفجر المفاجاه
بقولها انه على الرغم من العقوبات العديده
ضد روسيا فان واشنطن تواصل التجاره مع
موسكو عبر شراء الوقود النووي منها بنحو
مليار دولار
اتطلبون من الدول الابتعاد عن روسيا
وتقتربون انتم لياتي هنا الدور على الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين والذي اكد في خطاب
القاه بالنيابه عنه وزير الروسي ان
استخدام العقوبات غير المشروعه وتجاهل
مبدا المساواه بين الدول ونقض المعاهدات
في مجال الاستقرار الاستراتيجي هي اساليب
تلحق اضرارا بنظام القانون الدولي ومن حرب
العقوبات الى المعارك والاشتباكات على
الارض الاوكرانيه وبعد التقارير التي
افادت بتحقيق القوات الاوكرانيه اختراقات
في الخطوط الدفاعيه بمدينه بخموت حيث اكد
الجيش الاوكراني استعاده نحو كيلومترين في
محيط بخموت لتنفي روسيا حدوثه تلك
الاختراقات في مراكز القتال شرق اوكرانيا
وما ان اعلنت كييف تحقيق هذا الاختراق حتى
تاما مؤسس فاجنر الروسيه
جنود الجيش الروسي بالفرار من مواقعهم في
منطقه دونيتسك شرق اوكرانيا فما كل هذه
الانباء المتضاربه هل هناك شيء يطبخ على
نار هادئه ومن جانب اخر وبسبب نقص لدى
روسيا والتي تواجه الجيش الاوكراني
باسلحتها المتقدمه عادت موسكو لاستخدام
الدبابات السوفيتيه القديمه التي اثبتت
جدارتها في العديد من ساحات الحرب سابقا
لتشارك في الحرب الاوكرانيه ذلك وفق
التقارير الغربيه لكن البعض يتحدثون عن ان
هذه الدبابات هي فقط مجرد طعم روسي
لاستدراج القوات الاوكرانيه وبينما تدور
رحل حرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه بين القوتين
مع كر وفر للطرفين هنا ظهر جندي روسي
انتهت ذخرته اثناء القتال في محيط مدينه
بخموت ليبشر ويعرض الاستسلام فجاه للقوات
الاوكرانيه نعم لقد رفع يديه مستسلما
لطائره مسيره اوكرانيه ليقوم مركز التحكم
بالمسيره بجعلها تقتاده بالفعل الى موقعهم
ليتم اسره ليصبح اول اسير في العالم
تاثيره طائره بدون طيار ومن ضجه الحرب الى
سبل السلام حيث اعلنت الصين ان مبعوثها
الخاص لشؤون اوراسيا سيبدا جوله تشمل
اوكرانيا وروسيا وعددا من الدول الاوروبيه
لاجراء مناق تهدف الى ايجاد حل سياسي
للازمه الاوكرانيه فهل ينجح اصحاب العيون
الضيقه بما فشل به العالم لننتقل الى جبهه
اخرى من الجبهات الروسيه ولا تاخذون خريطه
الاحداث الى نعم هذه المدينه التي قد يشعل
اسمها معركه عسكريه بين روسيا وبولندا
وذلك بسبب القرار الاخير لبولندا والتي
اقترحت تغيير اسم المدينه في الافلام
الوثائقيه الى اسمه القديم في الحقبه
السوفييتيه حيث كان اسمها
[موسيقى]
ووصفه بالعمل العدائي فهل نشهد حرب جديده
بين روسيا وبولندا وفي جبهه اخرى طرفها
هذه المره واشنطن وموسكو مع وجود عربي
للقاهره حيث تجاهلت مصر عده طلبات امريكيه
لاغلاق مجالها الجوي امام الرحلات
العسكريه الروسيه بهدف قطع الطريق المتبقي
امام موسكو الى قواعدها الاستراتيجيه في
سوريا وذلك وفقا صحيفه وولو الامريكيه
بينما كان الجنرال اللكزس قائد القوات
الجويه في القياده المركزيه للقوات
المسلحه الامريكيه
الطائرات الروسيه تحلق باستمرار فوق
رؤوسنا نشرا الى ان طائرات موسكو نفذت ما
لا يقل عن 25 تحليقا فوق قاعده التنف
العسكريه الامريكيه في سوريا خلال شهر
واحد
الرشقات الصاروخيه لا تتوقف
غارات وهجمات اسرائيليه مكثفه على غزه
يقابلها وابل من الرشقات الصاروخيه من
المقاومه الفلسطينيه تعلن بلديه بيت شمش
قرب القدس عن فتح الملاجئ بحسب صحيفه
يدعوت تل الاسرائيليه ليسفر القصف
الاسرائيلي على القطاع منذ فجر الثلاثاء
عن
[موسيقى]
من قاده سرايا القدس ولكن المقاومه
الفلسطينيه لم تسكت وبشرت باطلاق رشقات
صاروخيه كثيفه تجاه غلاف القبه الحديديه
للكيان ليصل عدد الصواريخ الفلسطينيه
المطلقه على المستوطنات والمدن المحتله
منذ بدايه هجمات الاحتلال على غزه نحو
اكثر من الف صاروخ ولكن هنا لا تظهر
الخسائر الاسرائيليه انما الخساره
الحقيقيه هي خساره اكثر من مليون دولار مع
كل صاروخ يطلق من مقلاع داوود من اجل
اسقاط صاروخ فلسطيني لبضعه الاف الدولارات
فوق منطقه تل ابيب الكبرى وهذا باختصار هو
حال الكيان بعد الرد الغزاوي بينما اعلن
قائد نظام بطاريه القبه الحديديه
الاسرائيليه المضاده للصواريخ انهم جاهزون
ل
من وجهه نظر التكنولوجيه وانظمه فعن اي
جهوزيه يتحدث وصواريخ غزه تتبختر في اجواء
تل ابيب لتدخل حركه حماس على خط هذه
المواجهات وذلك بعد ان ابلغ الوسيط المصري
تل ابيب انه اذا انتهى اليوم وغدا ولم يتم
التوصل لتهدئه مع الجهاد الاسلامي فان
حماس ستدخل بالمواجهه بشكل علني فهل هناك
ما تخبئه حماس للكيان الاسرائيلي الاحداث
والتطورات اعلنت مسؤوله امريكيه ان
الولايات المتحده تسعى لمنع تحول خلافاتها
مع الصين بشان تايوان الى نزاع مع بكين
ومن جانب اخر اكدت الصين ان خطط حلف شمال
الاطلسي النيتو لفتح مكتب له في اليابان
تثير قلقا كبيرا للمجتمع الدولي وخاصه دول
اسيا والمحيط الهادئ وقال المتحدث وزاره
الخارجيه الصينيه في مؤتمر صحفي
اليابان على استخلاص الدروس من التاريخ
وانت تبقى ملتزمه بمسار التنميه السلميه
وتجنب القيام باشياء من شانها ان تزعزع
الثقه وتؤثر على السلام والاستقرار في هذه
المنطقه قال وزير الخارجيه السعودي فيصل
بن فرحان ان الاتفاق الذي وقع في جده بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع ياتيك
خطوه اولى ستتبعها خطوات اخرى واضاف ان
الاهم هو الالتزام بما تم الاتفاق عليه
تجهز مجموعه من اعضاء الكونجرس الامريكي
مشروع قانون جديد يهدف الى تعزيز قدره
الحكومه الامريكيه على فرض عقوبات كتحذير
للدول الاخرى من تطبيع العلاقات مع الرئيس
السوري بشار الاسد حسب ما افاد موقع سويس
انفو اجازت اداره الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن يوم الخميس بيع مروح من طراز
الشينوك بقيمه ثمانيه مليارات ونصف
المليار دولار الى المانيا افرجت المحكمه
العليا في اسلام اباد عن رئيس الوزراء
السابق عمران خان بعد حكمها بعدم قانونيه
قرار اعتقاله وكان اعتقال خان ادى الى
موجه احتجاجات واسعه في انحاء البلاد سقط
خلالها مئات المصابين من المحتجين وقوات
الامن الفصاروخ فلسطيني تجعل القبه
الحديديه ونظام راداراتها في خبر كان فكيف
سينتهي هذا التصعيد بين غزاوه تل ابيب
[موسيقى]